voilà c'est un texte qui divise mais qui
devrait être adopté sans encombre
oui en effet la séance a débuté il y a
presqu'une heure maintenant et le texte
comme vous l'avez dit elle devrait être
adoptée sans grande difficulté c'est une
victoire pour la république en marche
qui se réjouit mais de l'autre côté de
l'opposition et bien c'est une autre
ambiance
il fustige ce texte qui n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux politiques et qui
manquent de plusieurs sujets certains
vont voter contre et d'autres vont
s'abstenir
écoutez les contre toute attente
peut-être initial la réponse est non le
texte est un peu un peu racoleur et
pourraient correspondre à ce que nous
attendons effectivement lutter contre
les séparatismes sauf que par rapport à
l' annonce initiale
il ya un peu tromperie sur la
marchandise on est évidemment pour la
défense des principes de la république
ça va sans dire mais en réalité ce texte
ne fait que survoler un certain nombre
de questions les élus du rassemblement
national vont s'abstenir pour au moins
deux raisons la première c'est que ce
texte passe complètement à côté de ses
objectifs
il n'a pas atteint les objectifs qu'on
était en droit d'attendre la lutte
contre l'islamisme est un problème dans
notre pays éminemment important et bien
ce texte ne l'atteint pas ne règle pas
le problème on en est même très
éloignées
et puis évidemment comment voter un
texte qui fait l'impasse sur les sujets
notamment de l'immigration qui veut pas
faire le lien entre immigration et lutte
contre l'islamisme
pour toutes ces sujets là il est
difficile de voter puis dernier point si
j'ose dire il vient entamer des libertés
fondamentales qu'ont les français
je veux très content parce qu'il passe à
côté et que c'est une opération de
communication
on va il n'aborde pas la question du
voile notamment des fillettes amendement
déposé par la majorité il n'aborde pas
la question du financement des lieux de
culte étrangers où je veux l'interdire
pour éviter la mainmise de la turquie
sur des lieux de culte français et il
n'aborde pas la question centrale de
l'immigration
or comment vous voulez traiter le
séparatisme si vous ne traitez pas la
submersion migratoire c'est impossible
donc c'est tu en fait un projet de loi
de communication qui n'aborde pas
l'essentiel
et du côté des socialistes qui ont
refusé de répondre à nos questions et
bien ce sera l'abstention il regrette
que le texte choix répressive
quant à la france sans soumises et bien
ils voteront contre le texte qui selon
eux stigmatise et les musulmans et
serait contraire à à l'analyse
t alors si ce projet de loi est
divisible fixe qui veille des débats
pendant des semaines et des semaines et
bien il faut savoir que ce sujet est
bien et dans dans les tiroirs du
gouvernement depuis un moment déjà
souvenez-vous le discours d' emmanuel
macron 2 octobre 2020 au mur on le
président de la république détaillé son
plan d'action contre le séparatisme
lui qui voulait donner une image de
fermeté accusé dans le passé de
tergiverser sur le sujet c'est un agent
un des chantiers de ce quinquennat et
bien c'est chose faite
et concernant l'opinion publique vous
l'a vu également plusieurs
rassemblements ont été organisés pour
dénoncer ce texte de loi qui est accusé
selon certains d'être discriminatoires
envers les musulmans et l'hôtel au vote
sur ce texte interviendra dans quelques
heures merci beaucoup aux namouh dès
lors en direct de l'assemblée nationale